vous vous en souvenez c'était le 12
octobre
cette information a fait les gros titres
des journaux la télévision a consacré
plusieurs de ses émissions à l'événement
marie-claire 17 ans accusée d'avortement
a été relaxé son défenseur maître gisèle
halimi explique comment cette relaxation
qui fait jurisprudence est une étape
importante pour la suppression de la loi
répressive de l'avortement est déjà une
première étape parce que marie claire a
été relaxé alors qu'elle reconnaissait
avoir commis les faits qu'elle a indiqué
qu'elle avait choisi librement de le
faire et qu'elle en avait parlé à sa
mère ensuite et en troisième lieu à la
10 à la fin de l'audience qu'elle ne le
regrettaient pas par conséquent il y
avait bien un délit
ils avaient été commis et reconnu il y
avait bien une culpabilité puis ce qui
est un délit mais il semble que les
juges en indiquant que marie-claire
n'avait pas délibérément et librement
choisie cela que la cub qu'ils aient
attribué la culpabilité ailleurs et par
conséquent à la société à la loi mais ça
n'est qu'une étape
l'autre étape c'est le 8 novembre
prochain devant le tribunal de bobigny
devant lesquels vont comparaître sa mère
et ses complices et devant lesquelles
j'ai cité un certain nombre de témoins
qui vont parler de la loi qui ont
accepté comme le professeur jacques
monod prix nobel de médecine
monsieur jean rostand de l'académie
française monsieur rocard député des
yvelines
monsieur wallon député paris simone de
beauvoir présidente de l'association
dont je suis moi-même secrétaire général
l'association choisir qui se bat
précisément pour la suppression de tous
ces textes répressifs et là je crois que
le jugement du 8 novembre va être
déterminant ne croyez vous pas que la
libéralisation de l'avortement
face au recul et la contraception dont
vous voyez vous la libye ce weed les
bars bien sûr nous parlons à liberté
c'est pas la même chose
ça n'est pas nous ne voulons pas que
l'avortement soit permis seulement dans
certains cas nous voulons qu'en toute
hypothèse et en dernier ressort la femme
et la femme seule soit libre de choisir
nous considérons que l'acte de
procréation est un acte de liberté et
aucune loi au monde ne peut pas obliger
une femme à avoir un enfant
si elle ne se sent pas capable d'assumer
cette responsabilité
alors pour répondre à votre question je
vous signale que notre association a
trois objectifs le premier temps la
contraception le deuxième suppression de
toutes les des textes répressifs et le
troisième défense gratuite de tous les
inculpés justement d'avortement donc
tout cela l'avortement n'est qu'un volet
du problème l'autre étant précisément le
choix libre d'une maternité heureuse et
par conséquent cela implique une
contraception mais il faut bien dire que
la montagne dont nous parlons ici dont
nous parle monsieur neuwirth depuis un
certain temps d'accoucher que d'une
souris m halimi vous avez trois enfants
est-ce que vous avez choisi de leur
donner la vie
j'ai choisi d'avoir mes trois enfants et
je dois dire que surtout en ce moment
peut-être parce que ils deviennent de
grands garçons les deux aînés en
particulier ils ont 20 ans et 17 ans 3e
à 8 au jeu sans à chaque moment à quel
point ç'a été pour très très important
pour moi de les choisir je sens à chaque
moment combien je m'en sens responsable
et quelle joie c'est pour moi vous les
appelez signé je les dis publiquement et
j'ai avorté à des moments de ma vie où
j'avais absolument senti qui ne m'était
pas possible d'assumer une naissance car
a subi in les sens ça ne veut rien dire
tout seul voici mes naissance et assumer
quand même une vie c'est accompagner un
enfant et cela il faut être capable de
le faire quand je n'ai pas été capable
de le faire j'ai avorté
personne au monde n'aurait pu m'en
empêcher
[Musique]